i want to just jump straight into this
next story because uh this is about
brennan taylor's mother she's meeting
with doj and demanding federal charges
against the officers and the brown
tailor at death so this took place in
2020 this story's significant for a few
reasons one it plays into the heart of
what i've been saying over the past
several weeks specifically trayvon
martin's story was fake the michael
brown story was fake the george floyd
story was heavily lied about the almond
arbory story heavily lied about all
these stories i say they're fake i'll
clarify they were all
extreme exaggerations and manipulations
by the media to the point where in the
in the george zimmerman incident with
trayvon martin they edited the audio i
think it was nbc nbc news yeah they
edited the audio to make it sound like
he was racist they cut out key context
they've done this for basically every
single major story that's resulted in
black lives matter riots and then when
you try and get the real story if you're
able to get it's like all of a sudden
you go wow
now the interesting thing here is
republicans have a general polling
advantage
from real player politics about 3.4
points and with 530 about 2.2 points
when democrats have a five point
advantage or less they lose seats in the
house republicans have a ga have an
advantage which is to suggest that
people aren't falling for these stories
anymore here's where it gets crazy so
we're sitting here with uh john
mattingly you were there you were
involved in the whole incident and the
media and the activists are still lying
about what happened trying to put
pressure on the government to make
changes and to get certain politicians
elected right so
we'll we'll start here like what's this
story about now we can go back and you
can we can get into the the details yeah
so this was just a couple weeks ago um
they went to d.c her and ben crump the
the clown that that guy yeah that runs
around and destroying cities and takes
his money and jets he's a lawyer right
yeah yeah
and which i guess
well i mean he can barely put two
sentences together i don't know how he's
a lawyer but you know he just mumbles
and jumbles when he talks um so they
went there and they met with the doj and
the funny thing is
you know during all this i requested
meetings with the fbi denied wouldn't
talk to me
they've met with them several times
and i'm thinking
how are you only talking to one side
that doesn't make sense to me but anyway
that's that's a whole nother thing so
she went there and they talked about um
you know what's going on the case when
are you going to do something when are
you going to do something and
the very next day
uh katie cruz was indicted by the feds
or two days later is day or two later
and who is katie cruz so katie cruz so
the day when when all these riots
started the first night in louisville
there were seven people shot
in the the very first night of riots
downtown boom boom boom people were
being just crazy
and so the next night um you know the
police presence was still there it was
still heavy things were still
out of control
the crowd had moved from downtown
because they were blocking streets off
and stuff took to more toward the west
end of louisville and we're at 26th and
broadway there's a little store there
that it's called dinos and it's always
been a super problem area shootings
robberies
drug activity just it's just out of
control area so
however
these people were no longer rioting
because they were in their neighborhood
it was basically a huge
block party i mean the people were
shooting guns they were doing illegal
stuff but
they weren't causing destruction like
downtown they weren't you know doing the
the things that would require
police presence to
be forceful
and so
our department decided that they were
going to send officers down there to
clear it out they were breaking the
curfew that was enacted by the mayor
which
i don't agree with those either but
so
when they sent them down there to
enforce this curfew and make all these
people leave this lot
there was some activity going on i think
there were some gunshots right down the
block
and two other crews from what i've heard
had turned down the request by the
chief's office wow go down there and
take it they went by looked they said
too dangerous out of control i'm not
putting my guys in that that situation
okay so he called another one nope not
put my guys in that situation they
called the third group
he sent their people down there with the
national guard
so
katie
following commands they're like all
right if they won't disperse shoot some
pepper balls
that'll put the the oc in the air and
it'll it'll irritate people enough when
they go inside
she fired some pepper balls at that time
one of the business owners that owned a
barbecue shop right across the street
from that gas station comes out and
shoots a gun at them whoa so the
national guard fired back and killed it
right i remember this story yeah and so
just a couple weeks ago she was indicted
on civil rights violation for shooting
pepper ball whoa because they said her
shooting the pepper ball
caused him to think he was getting shot
at and he fired back
now how they can know
from a dead man what his thoughts were
you know shooting back at them pepper
balls do not sound like guns no no
anybody's going to a paintball range and
has ever gone to a gun range knows come
on and you know
that guy had video in his in his
business kind of like you have here you
know cameras all over so he had some
great angles and you could see
everything that happened
and our mayor would not release that
until the media found out there was good
video and pressured him and then he
released it because everything they do
is just just such
he comes out and says oh we're we are
very uh transparent transparency is the
way to be which it should be you should
be very transparent if you're if you're
operating on the government's dime and
they're paying you
there should be no stone uncovered
everything should be wide open if you
are a cop
these day right now
i'm telling you you're going to prison
yeah it's like it's no good they're hunt
they're head hunting yeah yeah look
we've seen all of these riots
summer is around the corner summer is
when riots pick up i'm not entirely
convinced it'll be nearly as bad as 2020
a lot of people were they were angry for
a lot of reasons you know covid locked
them down people were on edge we may see
things get pretty crazy especially
considering it's an election year we got
the midterms coming up and it's going to
be serious if if democrats lose the
house
it's going to be somebody crazy yeah so
so i'll tell you see all the all the
cops out there
they're going to get called out yeah
they're going to get called out to a
riot and they're going to be and they're
going to get be given a reasonable order
as it pertains to a violent ride of
people smashing windows and burning
things down
something will happen you'll go to
prison and here's the catch-22 in that
i've sworn an oath to protect and serve
and
as a citizen i'm looking at the police
going
why are you not acting when they're
burning our stuff down
you know now they're being told by
command they do they follow orders
unfortunately sometime that's good
sometime that's bad but they're
following orders and they're told to
stand down
and a lot of them are looking at it now
what you just said tim they're going if
i act i'm going to prison screw that
that building ain't worth me going to
prison good so so they're staying down
so now you the the citizens are mad at
you because you're letting stuff burn
the the the government's mad at you if
you do act or they come at you so it
it's a no incident it's not too bad
too bad for the citizens too bad for too
bad for the civilians who wouldn't say
hey maybe it's reasonable that we have a
police force that's going to stop people
burning buildings down if they won't
stand up for the cops that are going out
just trying to stop rioting
well then you deserve what you get and
that's cops being like look if you don't
got my back i don't got yours i can't
yeah i was just like let's go that's the
city you get i think it's really i think
it's unbelievably horrific for a police
officer to fail to do their duty to fail
to protect the people that they're
supposed to protect at the same time if
you're a citizen and you're lamenting
this ask yourself the question if one of
these police officers acted in a way
which was justified to protect somebody
else's livelihood and prevent their
business from being burned down and then
they were placed on trial and the media
was calling them a terrible racist would
you say anything would you say anything
to the people at work who were calling
that man a racist for trying to protect
people probably not no i mean
statistically probably not so it's not
just that police officers aren't doing
their jobs they certainly aren't but
nobody is no one's standing up for the
things they're supposed to stand up for
no one is standing up for civility this
country's falling apart man well it's
like we're here yeah our viewers are
here we're we're we're a community
people who care there are a lot of
people in this country who care but
there's too many people even who do
who they care about what's going on are
unwilling to speak up
you know
from personal experience i can tell you
we've reached out to a lot of people if
you're willing to have me on other
people are but there's a lot of people
who still do not want to attach my name
to anything you name them do you want to
name them you want to call anybody out
no you don't have to no i don't want to
here's what i'll call out so i'm
supposed to we were supposed to go speak
in ohio i won't give you the city but
we're supposed to go speak in ohio in on
in april
and
they were going to use a training
facility of this police department
and the police department was still
charging them they would charge them to
use their facility
and
once they put the flyer out and it
showed my picture on it the chief of
that department said no you're not using
our training facility he's not welcome
here for just a training it was it's a
support thing for spouses
who go through critical incidents
and they and and and this group that was
bringing us in is huge on bringing the
community and the police together to try
to to try to merge them you know you
know what i think is that uh we often
talk about the problems of policing you
know i've certainly complained about the
cops who are enforcing covet lockdowns
and interesting owners but but it's not
it's it's not a police problem like this
but particular instance when a cop when
this cop arrests a salon owner like yeah
that was a cop problem the problem is
just cultural and moral decay in the
united states extends
beyond the population and into police
departments so what happens is you'll
get a dude who's uh he works maybe at a
um an insurance company and they're
doing a bunch of or how about this he
works at a home depot and then home
depot comes out and says everybody you
got to do the woke stuff i think this
was in canada they did this and that guy
says i'm not going to say anything
because
my my my protecting myself and my assets
is more important i don't want my family
to be sick or starve now i can certainly
understand that what that means is the
the the cultural and moral connections
of our society are gone granted that
happened in canada but just an example
if you work for a company and you won't
speak up
that for that same reason neither will
firefighters neither will police neither
will politicians not nobody would that
kind of goes back to your point which
you made a few minutes ago
where
it's our job to protect the city but you
said you can understand why they
wouldn't
but well this is right i understand but
at what point do you go okay no matter
what my sacrifice is i'm willing to go
out there because i want change no this
is exactly my point that when regular
people aren't showing up to city
meetings being like look we understand
police reform can be done and there are
problems people are upset about but at
the very least stopping a riot should
not be questionable but they don't do it
these people are going to be like i'm
not going to say anything because then
they'll come and ride at my house yeah
and and okay well then the cops aren't
going to do anything and you know what's
worse the cops are going to show up to
your house when you're the victim and
arrest you you see that guy in wisconsin
guy was in his house blm showed up the
mccluskies no no no no in wisconsin a
guy was in his house
blm showed up to his house protesting
the same organizer organized a previous
protest and that set fire to another
house
so this guy brandishes a shotgun through
his window as one should i mean if
people are going to potentially burn
your house down that's not not to be
fair i'm not giving people advice and
saying you should do that i don't think
you should just you don't think nobody
was going to point a gun at them but i
think that's why people know that you're
okay well then no brandishing was he he
pointed the shotgun towards the window
at the crowd yeah no then you should
have done it you should not holding it
up i'd be like fine whatever yeah either
way you're in your own house yes i i
have questions about first of all i can
say don't point your weapon at someone
else you have ever ever ever ever unless
you intend to use it that being said if
you're on your own property
and you're and you're holding your
weapon
you know
there's questions there but ultimately
the real issue is the cops showed up
went to his house and arrested him to
cheers from black lives matter yeah they
cheered the same group that wants to
abolish the police was cheering when the
police did did what they wanted they'll
go into your house and arrest you the
mccloskey is our good example though
they broke on a private property
destroyed the fence the mccloskeys came
out armed on their own property as
they're legally allowed
she was she was appointed she was
dangerous with it she didn't know what
she was doing but she did point out you
can see your point at least one guy okay
and people thought this guy's boom mic
on his camera was a gun but hold on
there a minute a guy was holding a black
object with a boom mic
yeah sure in hindsight you can tell it's
not a gun did she know that no the
adrenaline's flowing right you've got
even training people you can train
people that's tough in that quick of a
second to distinguish but somebody
that's not trained coming out with that
adrenaline dump and the fear i mean
your rationale it just goes away a
little bit yeah well i mean also you
have to consider if you're in your house
and you're with your family and there
are people outside of your house who as
you mentioned burned down a house
previously it's again you should never
ever point a gun at people if you're not
willing to use it but um
for for people to know that you have
some ability to protect yourself is
obviously a good thing for you and your
family and your security if you're going
to burn my house down i'm going to use
it yeah like well if someone's exactly
if someone tries to burn your house down
they should know that it's on the table
like well if you try to burn my house
down and kill my family i will i will
shoot you to prevent that from occurring
you have the right to defend yourself
yeah from from this violence and all
this stuff
so here we go what i like to say you
know especially in the past several
weeks just name a story around black
lives matter and it was fake
name a single black lives matter story
that wasn't fake
i mean this is not not true i want to
make sure to clarify people died yes
there there is obviously some some
things were done wrong or improperly but
the point is the media narratives coming
out of all of these stories were untrue
to some degree yeah and this is part of
why i really want to to dig into this is
because as someone on the the right and
somebody's very skeptical of blm and
their narratives part of what sort of
convinced me on the the brianna taylor
case and again this is some coming from
someone who didn't pay as close
attention to it as they did some of the
other ones is that you know even rand
paul
was saying that we should end no not
grades which i agree with but he titled
his bill after brianna taylor
justice for brianna taylor so to me
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm we'll see you all there